dura
39 challenge estremo perché oggi ci
saranno in palio delle cose super
speciali hanno detto che se lo sconto
video pop it challenge avesse raggiunto
i 10 mila mi piace perché ho fatto
un'altra pomice challenge è raggiunto i
30 mila mi piace grazie mille se anche
questo video raggiunge il 10 mila mi
piace o li supera ci sarà un'altra
pocket challenge iii laham ora mettetevi
comodi lasciati un mi piace breve di hip
hop corner esistiamo capita la sfida
primo round
io ti offro un cavallino aspetta aspetta
un attimo aspetta un attimo perché
aggiungo anche un'opzione questa opzione
ti permette di trasformare il cavallino
in un
giorno ma chi vi cavallino più ritorno
in un palladino offerta e tu che cosa
offre ieri e il cappellino di giorno che
io ti offro un po pitt che secondo me ti
somiglia somiglia meglio sorriso anche
voi scrivete nei commenti il secondo voi
famiglia vitale questo compito di
milano
se doveste migliorato avvisare guardate
quindi ti offre il pop hit che ti
somiglia in cui ben più ma gli occhiali
quindi accetti amici piazzare un attimo
di sviluppo e va bene ti offro anche un
po pitt super carino nello store subito
e se avrete detto che uno dei vostri
preferiti in assoluto e gioia
[Musica]
perché mi ruberà chicco da grande che ha
non puoi non accettare quella che bei
questi pochi volpino e mamma katie
stoviglia accetti allora penso proprio
che accetterò
e voi avreste fatto questo scambio
scrivetecelo nei commenti ma ora tocca a
me offrire dei pochi secondo round ti
offro il granchio
anzi aggiungo un'altra cosa che cosa è
anche l'arco balena che so che ti piace
un sacco
allora ti offro una bomba l'eroe della
farfallina volante a palena poiché offre
altri c'era dopo no è un piacere l'idolo
20 e va beh non far niente di te lo
tieni poi per scambiare quindi farfalla
triceratopo è anche presidente centro a
tutto anche consegnato un baleno e 3 pop
hit di sto offrendo in cambio di chi 2
anche se il dinosauro non mi piace tanto
si come è messo il pop in sicilia non
accetta l'idea di andare non li e
valeria
non è proprio quello supergigante però è
grande e quindi cresciuto
che ne dite secondo poi ho fatto un
buono scambio
io questa volta ti offro solo un po pitt
sì ma è molto bello molto ricercato
molto importante molto introvabile e
cioè
il compito
che bella sì infatti no mi sa che lo
tiene d'occhio cosa più fama ei
non mi interessa questo faccio io voglio
la tastiera dai detto che mi preme la
zattera tra mia tastiera tu che cosa
per la tastiera che mi piace un sacco
posso offrirti il poker face e rosa che
a me piace un sacco perché rosa poi ti
posso aprire il dinosauro verde visto
che a te piace i dinosauri verde oggi
sei vestito di verde non
usarla anche el poi il polipetto
porpetto quelli the polipo oporto poco
istituito come dice il polpo paul getty
colpetto giallo allora mi dai una
tastiera perfetti sembra interessante io
ti sto dando la goccia tu mi stai dando
33 poppins
quelle tastiere al mondo nessuno
tastiera affetto no non puoi anche te
non puoi accettarli ne della carriera
perché aiuto offerto la vostra tutela
offerta con i train andria no certo
ieri la tua voce
che non c'era il pop sopra il tavolo non
conta c'era solo la goccia sopra il
tavolo quindi
cosa qui tre pubbliche per questo misero
bobbit doccia dove avevi pro verso la pa
e avrei dovuto aspettare tv italiana
mette sul tavolo degli scambi mi
vendicherò per questo sacca mi tocca a
me offrire anche se sono molto
arrabbiata perché vitale di ha fregato
nell'altro non devi essere arrabbiata
con me di essere cambiata contengano 36
accorta che la tastiera non c'era sul
tavolo non ti preoccupare su un piano
per tecnologia che piano vedrai
per questo round ti offro questo può fit
cerchio lumaca guarda è lo stesso
identico colore del tavolo la quale un
girasole
a proposito di verde verde menta
tre
bellissimi pop e brevissimi ma mi sembra
contro tutti questi pubblica nei brutti
[Musica]
fantastico per me quello arriverà
anche i ti offro subito come cosa allora
ti offro un casco imparare
e gli offre un'altra cosa anche
bla bla bla tutto giallo dai la
passerella è carina però il casco di
bravura e quindi secondo me ci siamo
come scambio è molto strano che è vitale
off road del pop hit cibo in cambio
pubblico e mal cibo che strano forse
perché tu vuoi più pop hit quindi dando
due papi che vuoi 3 pop hit quindi
interessa più la quantità li può anche
il conte richards
ha visto che vi è anche più banali che
la povera
il fiore invece i
semi di girasole si mangiano vediamo e
basta beh che vivono qui per l'anno
prossimo turno adesso allora io ho
deciso di fare una cosa vi offrirò una
selezione di vini pop hit tipo questo
cupcake rosa e questo mix è il cardo
baleno questo gattino con l'unicorno e
poi
lo ricorda poi la cagnetta colorata un
fantasmino guarda quante ne sto offrendo
poi aggiungo anche questo e poi aggiungo
anche questo quando viene offerta
con le anas silea stai cercando di
liberarsene no io stavo solo cercando di
darti un pacchetto di va bene che volevo
rifilare tutte le anime se mio figlio le
rodio lo sapevo ma io non le odio le
aree astenuto perché le odi non capisco
il perchè no perché di quei compiti
miniatura quindi ti offro una fragola
arcobaleno pastore
il blitz che si illumina al buio e altro
po fesr taibo ii cupcake e il limone
anche se non ti piace il liquore allora
ha effettivamente io ho offerto tutto
questo kit di mini pop hit per lei mi ha
offerto quattro posti tutti i grandi e
già chigi va quindi az
secondo me sto per fare un ottimo
scambio quindi
sì un altro po più di tanto è vero che
quelle aree si è liberato di tutte le
ore il prossimo round iniziamo con le
cose più grandi e
sky.it grande
martoglio e crede e poi il pop il cuore
gigante un bellissimo mi offrì per
questi due pop hit e giganti
dai adesso ti offro qualcosa stavo solo
scherzando
ok visto che siamo in sei visto che
siamo in ambito arcobaleno di offro
porti guido arcobaleno vero e basta sì
perché volevi qualcos'altro che sto
prendo due compiti giganti quindi
assolutamente di più ti offro una meta
mio augurio ma non bene quali sono pochi
piccoli il confronto frutti due compiti
giganti quindi di più ok allora restando
in tema arcobaleno di otto buche violino
arcobaleno
dinosauri atto arcobaleno e infine un
cup cake marcobaleno quasi va bene e che
dato io prima no no quello che mi hai
dato tu prima e questo vede che è
differente mi dispiace ma non ci siamo
proprio
ma i miei sono girati qui ne sono tanti
e tutti sono il frutto a2 saluto noi
sono i tuoi
accettata città e società accesa
o hai rifiutato
me li riprende visto che non hai capito
il valore di questi popoli tre giganti e
tocca a me adesso e io ti offro un
cilindro di mobyt
questo gigante donati che sento
l'odore
[Musica]
ma
allora ti ho proibito gigante che non
sembra fisica
e votate quel di velo sopra l'altro è
solo un pezzetto piccolo e poi da questo
è opaco mentre questo è uscito purtroppo
mi sono rimasti pochissimi pop hit
queste milkshake di 12 ore questa dieta
è tutta qualche prima si è votato e ora
in occasione di accettare toyota di
grazia che è quella che tutti prima io e
altri team salewa viola questa bello ma
il brutto erano scritti piace davvero mi
piace ma secondo telecom è messo ad
accettare le giustificazioni
dai quali gigante no dai accetto perché
mi rimangono pochissimi po peter offen
sopra le altre ma come faccio ad
accettare questi pop in piccolissimi
minus che brutti che ti ho dato io a te
tutti brutti quindi
invece si chiede incubi riprendo il
tappeto gigante
non mi voglio troppi non li voglio i
tuoi pop hit di riprendermi un tappeto
gigante e me ne vado ciao o no va
comunque non c'era miliardi di buttarli
tutti così
però cosa potrei offrire io non mi vivo
le diete che interessi abitale questi
non gli piacciono un'idea che ebbe
offrire siccome non so che può pic to
voglia questo turno sarà un po diverso e
cioè
tutti i miei pop hit tranne quelli
giganti e tu puoi scegliere da questi
quelli che ti interessano di più
posso scegliere tra questi oppure li hai
messi tutti in palio qui sul tavolo una
devi scegliere quelli che ti interessano
questo il podio poi offerto niente
allora quali segni allora scelgo il
triceratopo e cavallino la paperella
l'ananas della cui tenere insieme questa
il fiore già cielo e doppione la caccia
dello small ata perché lo vi piaceva mi
ripeto la banana lo ricorda la farfalla
ascob alerno mi piace tanto e basta
dobbiamo vivere questo che cielo di
questo colore marrone vi prego tu devi
offrire qualcosa ma fai prendere il
coating è vero ti offro più ma non sono
certo quelli che non voglio più
no davvero così ora tu hai scelto quelli
qui di questi sono in palio dal mio lato
nord barbey e ora tu devi offrire
qualcosa per quest ipotesi allora che
cosa offre ok allora tiri offro per
vender di quelli che ti ha offerto io
poi ma tra l'altro io ti offro visto che
ti piaceva tanto
allora che fai al cerchio nel senso non
si è fatto che mi hanno voluto per
contenta di questo passo ma guardate che
grande lavoro e questi sono giorni
quindi prendo io partiamo ora all'ultimo
round
berlino ha accettato il voto di vitale o
se perfino grazie per avermi tenuto il
posto mentre mangia
sta rifacendo ovvero in bagno berlino mi
stava sostituendo momentaneamente vero
berlino che così accettato è studiato
che fatto in un arrivo ha deciso di
interrompere il gioco si è sdraiato sul
tavolo forse anche lui vuole essere
scambiato
cambiato persino da berlino lo puoi
dormire sul tavolo e il letto libri
dormire nel letto
inviare un po di crocchette questo
ultimo round ottenuto da parte il pezzo
migliore
ma per questo mi dovrei offrire a
tutti i pochi 3 anche di più è
sapere che cos'è il nuovo ruolo è
dura
[Musica]
ecco qua
cosa si disposta ad offrire
e bellissimo con che cosa può soffrire
per qualcuno accetterà mai niente
un'idea ti offro alto peso
dei topi tutti tutti quindi il cuore il
compito gigante tutte le
altre è il più il pop il tappeto che
abbiamo appena cambiato allora accetti
no ci vuole molto di più per il nuovo
iphone quindi più stoppa lo sapevo ma
non ho più può quindi devo mettere in
palio qualcos'altro aggiungo una cosa
che secondo me è fantastica
[Musica]
lo riconosci nei furgoni scorso
se avete visto la scorso video che lo
ricorderete molto bene anche berlino
interessato al rapporto netto regione
berlino e scioccato ma
berlino su cercando di adorare può
correggere allora mette in palio anche
nella foto né scorreggione così me ne
libero finalmente
allora non puoi vincere sa accettare
quest'offerta stupirmi di scopi un
fattore fiorenzani che tu ad ora
allora non vogliono accettare
è che se vi piace tantissimo devo
chiederti di più un
buon pure va bene non mi resta che
qualcosa da offrire
gestione costretta a prima
ma è sopratutto possibile parlare con
questo caso
allora guarda ti do freddo il mio apple
in perfette condizioni
e un ottimo affare perché tutto da tutti
i miei pochi più del pudore fornitore
più il mio
allora argenti e un ottimo cambia che
un'offerta che quasi non si può
rifiutare solo per l'epoca unesco
regione però
voglio di più perché non mi fido l'altra
volta che li fregato con la scatola
vuota cosa di più sono tutte quelle cose
e non ti preoccupare
ti faccio vedere guarda
ecco vedi è vero reale
mozionante quindi non sto cercando di
fregarti
allora accetti voglio comunque qualcosa
di mio
mi ricorda infatti gai che tu hai
qualcosa che io voglio che hai offerto
basta qualcosa che io che non ho certo
tu vuoi potrebbe essere solo cibo ho
capito
pochi per metterla nel nuovo iphone c'è
del mio iphone o capita sei furbo
puppet e va bene detto che questo è così
non mi rimarrà proprio più niente di pop
hit allora accetti non può soffrire
nient'altro non lo so ho bisogno di
rifletterci un po
chiederò la risposta è il bottone è il
bottone dimmi tu che cosa devo fare
bene
totti a me sembrava più no che cosa devo
fare
si è visto il lato addosso
[Musica]
accetto quella bordone e gente
ho fatto bene al cotone
ora lo apriamo assieme è per te il mio
iphone e tutti
voi avreste fatto questo scambio
scrivetelo nei commenti ma ora possiamo
aprire
moltissimo ma che offra la ho preso
tutti e tutti i pop hit ho preso il tuo
iphone è spenta e trovai canale e le
foto restò ragionissimo mi sembra più
contento per le foto che fra tutte le
cose
è arrivato per i pezzi del bondone
scorreggione
anche berlino sta guardando puoi vederlo
anche tu ho voluto rare vediamo se si
può mangiare
guardate che per colore
e proprio cell e stimo come gli occhi di
berlino
guarda che imperlano rimangiato uno
squarcio il cavo e le istruzioni ma
vogliamo la pellicola vediamo
se la pellicola anche qua dietro non c'è
la pellicola qua dietro a noi piace un
sacco colori celeste sono super contento
di questo scambio il mio invece cioè
quella della vita di priva del di alcol
e chissà magari
nella prossima challenge riusciremo a
scambiarli effettivamente celeste mi
piace nand sbaglio la dietro san marino
che volete giocare con noi siamo un nido
e che berlino vuole vorrei lasciarla
protetti ma
c'è chi dice no sono impegnato adesso mi
fa piacere
si sono berlino
voglio fare un ordine di 20 kg di
crocchetta potete consegnare subito ok
vi aspetto
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete
vedere la rivincita chissà se questo
iphone sarà in palio anche nella
prossima gialle sono state un bel mi
piace ora mi lasciavo fra quattro
candeline e cliccare per vedere i nostri
altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite
un pistone